[Musik]
guten tag haben sie auch schon einmal
darüber nachgedacht ob sie ihre rolle im
leben wirklich gefunden haben nicht auf
jemand ganz anderes sein könnten gar
mehr als nur eine persönlichkeit in sich
tragen
nun gibt es eine besondere art von
menschen die diese zweifel für uns
kultivieren und verkörpern nämlich
schauspieler vor allem als große
wandlungsfähige charakterdarsteller ein
solches ausnahme in die video ja
wahrhaftiges existenz chamäleon sitzt
nun gegenüber was ist der schauspieler
lars eidinger herzlich willkommen eine
sternstunde philosophie in halo existenz
kommunion
ja es ist toll ist eine falsche finde
ich super
wo wir gerade bei beschreibungen sind
ich habe man ein bisschen im archiv
gekramt und lese vor
ein experte für das maßlose ein
trauriger clown ein angst bündel ein
narzisst eine personifizierung neuer
männlichkeit wenn man sich dadurch
fertig geklebt hat man das gefühl dass
auf jeden fall mehr als eine person auch
mehr als ein typus beschrieben es ist
eigentlich gut zu doch also in je mehr
richtungen es geht desto besser für mich
glaube ich sind schon eine befreiung
wobei ich natürlich über manche
begrifflichkeiten stolperer ich habe
neulich im originalen film gesehen und
der wurde rampensau untertitelt gesagt
wurde aber stage animal das fand ich
irgendwie damit kann ich mich anfragen
rampen zu öffentlichen komischen begriff
aber stage in das animalische das ist
das was sie eigentlich sein wollen und
deswegen gefällt mir existenz chamäleon
ja weil weil ich doch je länger ich den
beruf mache immer mehr versuche aus dem
gestalterischen moment raus zu kommen
weil dann immer was rationales hat und
ich habe mal was ganz tolles gesehen in
der inszenierung von romeo castellucci
das war ein schwarzer hund auf einer
leeren weißen bühne also eine white box
und hinten gab es eine projektion die
lautet dieser hundes blind und dann hat
man zehn minuten einfach nur diesem hund
zugeschaut und das interessante war dass
der hund auf alles reagiert hat auch
dadurch dass er nicht sehen konnte und
und plötzlich hat man sozusagen mit dem
hund gehört also was ich dadurch
verstanden aber was eigentlich relativ
einfach ist dass man als spieler auf der
bühne den zuschauer verführen kann eine
sensibilität für sein umfeld zu
entwickeln und auch präsenz also ich
finde dass ein begriff der oft
missverstanden wird ich auf der
schauspieler auf der schauspielschule
wurde mir immer beigebracht es gibt
präsente schauspieler und es gibt nicht
präsent präsenz man sagt ja das wäre
auch dass man keinen einfluss hat aber
im grunde beschreibt dieses phänomen
präsenz finde ich dass dieser hund da
ist und dem zuschauer das gefühl
vermittelt er ist auch in dem moment da
unmittelbar und das finde ich das große
faszinosum von theater und das habe ich
darüber verstanden also diese
verlorenheit in fokussierter intensität
die man im theater erleben kann man kann
ja sagen bei tieren ist das immer da
die sind immer ganz im moment die
spielen aber auch keine rolle
das heißt ihre sind eigentlich die nicht
schauspieler an sich ja und danach
danach hat man eine sehnsucht also ich
das ist auch der grund warum ich viel
interagieren und improvisieren weil ich
tatsächlich das gefühl habe dem
zuschauer darüber überhaupt erst das
bewusstsein darüber vermitteln zu können
dass das was ich jetzt mache im moment
passiert das ist ja eigentlich kurios
dass so viele schauspieler sich so würde
ich es nennen hinter der verabredung
verstecken oder schützen darüber dass
sie was in der vergangenheit verabreden
was sie dann im moment präsentieren
das heißt ich krieg eigentlich was
gezeigt was gar keine gültigkeit für den
moment alles abgerufen wird aber genau
und das finde ich widerspricht einer
idee von präsenz bei präsenz beschreibt
der nichts anderes als ich bin in diesem
moment anwesend und auch der zuschauer
und das ist glaube ich auch der große
trumpf des theaters die unmittelbarkeit
aber so ganz entkommen sie hat den
zuschreibungen der andere nicht man kann
ja sagen die leute kommen ja überhaupt
bei uns theater um diesen eidinger zu
sehen
verdienen sie schon ideen haben der
seinen ganz besonderen
viel hat das heißt die idee sich ganz
frei zu machen von dem was die anderen
über einen denken oder schon zu wissen
meinen die ist ja letztlich hilflos da
kommt man nicht
ich glaube dass schließlich tatsächlich
auch aus also ich muss mich damit schon
konfrontieren dass ich beschreibe nur
dass es natürlich eine diskrepanz gibt
zwischen dem wie ich mich selber
wahrnehmen oder wahrgenommen werden will
und wie ich wahrgenommen werde
in karenz die muss da bleiben ja die
bleibt einfach zwangsläufig habe ich das
gefühl aber trotzdem kann ich mich mit
meinem image arrangieren ich kann es
auch zu einem großen teil nachvollziehen
woher es kommt aber interessanterweise
würde ich ganz einfach beschreiben das
ist oft so ist das gegenteil von dem was
ich als effekt darstellt der fall ist
also jemand wie ich der sehr komplex
beladen schüchtern zurückhaltend ist
erscheint natürlich weil er all das
versucht zu kompensieren durch den
energieaufwand er arrogant und und und
[Musik]
selbstbewusst also ich würde mich als
alles andere als selbstbewusst
beschreiben einfach weil ich sozusagen
jemand der selbst bewusst ist kann ja
dieses bewusstsein aus sich selbst
schöpfen ich brauche aber ich werde mir
selbstbewusst in der spiegelung also im
gegenüber und deswegen brauche ich
sozusagen die öffentlichkeit es gibt ein
ganz tolles gedicht von thomas brasch
ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt zusammen
kriege aber mein beruf heißt mich nicht
verstecken sondern öffentlich entdecken
mich finden in dem ich mich verliere
nicht bewahren für mich finden will ich
seit ich lebe und das beschreibt genau
das wie ich auch meinen beruf und da
sind ja schon echt ganz viele punkte
angesprochen erstmal die angst dann
dieses resonanz bedürfnis auch ein
selbstfindungs bedürfnis fangen wir doch
mal mit der resonanz an sie sind jetzt
ein theaterschauspieler auch
filmschauspieler sind seit dem zwölften
lebensjahr eigentlich vor der kamera auf
der bühne und letztes jahr etwas
passiert diese resonanz diese intensität
dieses spiegelung wurde ihnen genommen
und nicht nur ihnen sondern einer ganzen
zunft wie haben sie das erfahren
ja ich kann mich eigentlich kaum an eine
zeit erinnern wo ich diese
aufmerksamkeit nicht hatte und genossen
habe das war auch immer was was ich von
dem ich mir vorüber ich mir bewusst wahr
oder im klaren war das etwas ist was ich
einfach extrem brauche als
persönlichkeit dieses bespiegelt werden
von außen und das ist von einem moment
auf den anderen abgebrochen also ich bin
alleine seit 99 an der schaubühne
berliner schaubühne ein großes theater
genau da bin ich im festvertrag das
heißt ich bin da im ensemble als fest
angestellter mitarbeiter und habe in der
wahnsinnigen frequenz theater gespielt
also bis zu 25 vorstellungen im monat
und das seit 99 und das ist dann mit
einem mal im märz 2020 abgebrochen ist
der sonne hat drogenentzug dass da ein
wirklich eine substanz fehlt die der
körper zum leben braucht ja ich glaube
ja also das trifft es am besten einfach
ja weil das der spielerische moment
etwas rauschhaftes hat und auch wo man
sich tatsächlich selbst vergisst und das
ist ein großes thema also was hat was
bedeutet es sich selbst vergessen ich
würde zum beispiel immer behaupten was
auch paradox ist natürlich aber so ein
bisschen der schlüssel dazu den beruf
überhaupt verstehen zu koennen
dass sich in der verwandlung also
verwandlung in anführungszeichen aber in
der in dem moment wo ich eine rolle
spiele
mehr bei mir bin als in dem moment wo
ich jetzt hier alltäglich vor ihnen
sitzen irgendwo das ist glaube ich
wichtig zu verstehen also das ist ja
vollkommen dass geistiges rätsel dass
ein mensch der jemanden anderes
darstellt mehr bei sich sein soll als
mutmaßlich wenn er selbst ist ja aber
ich glaube es stimmt trotzdem
also ich glaube wir machen uns alle was
vor wenn wir das gefühl haben im alltag
sind wir bei uns und wir sind nicht sehr
vielen zwängen unterliegen die dazu
führen dass wir unsere persönlichkeit
doch nicht voll ausdrücken können und
ich habe einfach für mich gemeint ist
dieser dieser moment des ausdrucks oder
es veräußern es dazu führt dass
ich ein anderes verständnis von mir
selbst bekomme und dass ich gewisse
gefühle die ich in mir habe
die sonst nicht ausdrücken kann aus
welchen gründen auch immer in aus der
figur oder mit dem mit dem mit dem
ventil oder ja also oder im grunde wie
ein katalysator der figur zum ausdruck
bringen kann
und im grunde hat es tatsächlich was
auch mit sich von sich selbst entfernen
zu tun weil ich würde behaupten dass das
es mir schwer fällt über gewisse
problematiken die mich ausmachen im
klaren zu werden einfach weil ich keinen
abstand habe und in dem moment wo ich
sie ausdrücke und eigentlich vor mir
projiziert sehe kann ich kann nichts
kann ist viel besser einordnen oder oder
mich dazu verhalten und also zum
beispiel so eine kleine anekdote auf der
schauspielschule wurde immer gesagt ich
werde nie böse spielen kann also ich
werden die charaktere spielen können die
böse sind weil ich eine viel zu liebe
nette ausstrahlung habe und es nicht nur
interessant vor dem hintergrund für was
ich heute stehe oder welche rollen mir
zugeschrieben werden ja und mich hat es
damals beschäftigt weil ich dachte das
sind vielleicht gerade die rollen die
mich interessieren
und ich habe dann eine sogenannte wahl
rolle gemacht also eine rolle die man
sich selber erarbeitet und hat franz
moor gespielt der von schiller im grunde
von richard den dritten abgeschrieben
ist aber so wie ich das in kandierte
böse herr auch gar nicht unbedingt
subtil böse sondern einfach nur böse und
dann dachte ich wenn ich denen spiele
und allen zeigen dass ich das kann dann
traut man mir vielleicht diese
charaktere zu haben habe ich das richtig
verstanden
sie sehen das als eine art
therapeutische erfahrung in eine rolle
zu gehen die sehr weit von ihnen weg ist
um eine spiegelung auf sich selbst damit
zu bewirken zu beschreiben ein beispiel
sei keine rolle
die wm ist mir gleich mal anschauen es
geht um den film schwester leiden der
auch für den schweizer filmpreis
nominiert ist und sie spielen in diesem
film einen berühmten berliner theater
schauspieler ein shakespeare darsteller
der in einem endstadium an krebs leidet
schauen was kurz mal den ausschnitt an
der mit dem austausch eines komas sie
sterne in ihrer bahn aufhält und sie zum
stehen bringt ist schockierte zeugen
das ist bin ich der könig die dänen
ich hätte gedacht dass die guten geister
genommen hast du nicht verrückt sieht
von seinem prinzen kannst du bist du da
hakt bis zu einem stadtkasse spiel heute
nur durch
ich bin bereit wenn es jetzt sagen soll
wird es nicht in der zukunft passieren
kann ist sicher in zukunft passiert dann
geschieht es jetzt wenn es jetzt nicht
geschieht aber dass spieler passieren
bereit sein ist alles
es ist besser aus das ist ja toll
spenderin transportation hat ihren
schein gut getan
haidinger bereit sein das in einer rolle
in der es um sein und nichtsein geht man
kann ja sagen behandler haben dort geht
es auch um die versöhnung mit der
eigenen endlichkeit das ist die aufgabe
die als großes thema also sein oder
nichtsein ich kann mich wirklich
erinnern die premiere war damals in
athen weil es eine koproduktion war und
ich habe bis zur bis zum tag der
premiere bin ich nachts aufgewacht und
habe immer wieder gesagt jetzt weiß ich
worum es geht in dem monolog also das
ist ja ein monolog den jeder kennt im
grunde ich finde tatsächlich das sein
oder nichtsein zitat ist was sogar das
erste ist was einem einfällt wenn man
über kunst nachdenkt also das ist es
gibt keine elementare frage aber die
nächste zeile dieses sein oder nichtsein
glaube ich führte dann auf die
feststellung dass da jemand 1 1 ein
totenkopf liegt und dass der schon tot
ist und sich anschaut
wobei das sollte also es ist es ist
nicht die szene wo er den totenkopf
ihnen da das ja weil das wird immer so
dargestellt aber diese die szene wo er
den totenkopf in der hand hat ist diese
sogenannte prioritäre wo er den schädel
des narren in der hand hält und sagt ja
und was hast du da von dort sein ganzes
leben lang spaß machen gibt es ist wir
sehen unser schädel übrig es wird immer
so ein bisschen zusammen gebaut aber
trotzdem also dieses sein oder nichtsein
das ist die frage auf sein oder
nichtsein das ist die antwort auf sein
oder nichtsein was würden sie sagen na
philosophisch könnte man sagen menschen
sind die einzigen gewesen die wissen
dass sie sterben werden
sie sind in ihrem seien mit einem wissen
um ihr nicht sein geschlagen wir alle
wissen dass wir sterben werden das
wissen hunde wale und viele andere wesen
nicht und das ist schwierig hier zu sein
und zu wissen dass man den 100 jahren
nicht mehr hier ist ja vor allem was es
bedeutet nicht hier zu sein
also wir wissen ja weder was vordem vor
der geburt war noch was nach dem tod
kommt
also ich hab ich habe mich ja sehr viel
mit dem stück beschäftigt gab es fast
ritualisiert auch immer wieder gespielt
was ich auch interessant findet einfach
so als phänomen dass man sagt man
begegnet dieser frage immer wieder und
man findet auch immer wieder neue
antworten darauf
mittlerweile glaube ich dass die die
antwort auf sein oder nichtsein sein
oder nichtsein lautet dass das immer
ambivalent ist die plädiert ja ja genau
und letztendlich der letzte satz von von
hamlet ist auch hilfreich der rest ist
stille
das ist ja eine abhandlung von tabori
darüber dass die die übliche deutsche
übersetzung von krieg der rest schweigen
gar nicht korrekt ist in der hinsicht
weil schweigen immer die anwesenheit von
jemandem bedarf während stille
auch da herrscht keine anwesend ist aber
das stimmt ja auch ich meinen 200
millionen jahren der wahrscheinlich wird
auf diesem planeten stille herrschen das
german ist kein mensch mehr da der sich
irgendetwas anhört oder etwas wahrnimmt
ich finde das auch größen den gedanken
zu sagen was kommt denn nach dem tod
stille damit kann ich mich eigentlich
arrangieren
sie sagten vielleicht hängt das ja sogar
miteinander zusammen würde mich
interessieren die angst es das was sie
treibt die angst vor verschiedenen
dingen philosophisch könnte man sagen
die urangst jedes menschen ist die angst
vor dem tod vor der ungewissheit vor dem
faktum dass man sterben wird und vor dem
wissen dass man nicht weiß was dann ist
haben sie das gefühl dass ihre kunst
etwas mit dieser angst vor der
endlichkeit zu tun hat absolut also ich
glaube auch je älter ich werde je mehr
angst kriege ich vor dem tod also das
ist ja das war so eine erkenntnis die
mir auch noch mal klar wurde zusammen
mit dem film schwesterlein was bedeutet
es tatsächlich mit dem tod konfrontiert
zu sein und ich habe als kind immer sehr
viel mit dem tod kokettiert und habe
mich auch damals beim kindergeburtstag
aufs fensterbrett gestellt und gesagt
ich springe jetzt runter so weit weil
diese diese erkenntnis oder dieses
bewusstsein darüber zu erlangen sondern
man ist sterblich
und man hat es aber auch selber in der
hand unglaubliche macht ich kann das
jetzt beenden ja genau und damit habe
ich gespielt so und hab mir auch darin
gefallen aber je älter ich werde desto
mehr angst habe ich natürlich dass mein
leben zu ende geht und vor dem tod
tatsächlich und mich hatte es damals
sehr berührt die auseinandersetzung mit
christoph schlingensief und seiner
krebsdiagnose und die tatsache dass er
praktisch die angst vor dem tod
öffentlich gemacht hat und das taucht ja
auch als thematik in dem film auf da
heißt es dann per es jemanden beim
sterben zuzuschauen
und mich hat es sehr beeindruckt einfach
auch dahingehend dass ich gemerkt habe
ich jemand der dem tod nah ist oder der
unmittelbar mit dem tod konfrontiert ist
der erlangt nicht wie wir es gerne
hätten glaube ich größe oder eine
weisheit sondern der schrumpft im
gründen vor angst und und sich diese
angst einzugestehen und damit offensiv
umzugehen ich glaube das ist eine große
qualität also das versuche ich
eigentlich auch in der beschreibung dass
ich natürlich voll von angst bin also
thomas ostermeier der regisseur oder der
künstlerische leiter der schau bildet er
auch in dem film schwesterlein den
regisseur spielt er beschreibt mich
sozusagen als angstfreien menschen und
da sind wir im grunde bei dem was ich
vorhin gesagt habe dass der effekt an
sorten diametral ist also die haben doch
glaube ich das gesagt was passt schon
eine art schamanische ambition ist es
gibt eine situation die für uns alle
gilt und sie versuchen in ihrem
schauspiel uns in gewisser weise das
vorzuführen in aller öffentlichkeit in
einer schonungslosigkeit in einer
radikalität sie sind alle aber ich zeige
euch was das bedeutet jaja das fand ich
auch immer beeindruckend dass empathie
ja eigentlich oder mitleid meint dass
ich mich als zuschauer in diese person
rein projiziere und mit dieser figur
leide also eigentlich mir vorstelle das
würde mir geschehen
was ich in interessanten effekt finde
das ist gar nicht wirklich um mich geht
sondern jeder macht es mit sich aus und
das finde ich eigentlich die schönheit
auch am theater also diese möglichkeit
sich in den figuren zu spiegeln in
diesem film in der konstruktion gibt es
noch etwas anderes was mir sehr zu
denken gab nämlich dieser mann weiß dass
er stirbt aber er übt seine kunst bis
zum ende aus als ob er signalisieren
wollte er ist es egal dass das leben
endlich ist das ist es was mir sinn
verleiht und ich würde das bis zum
letzten atemzug tun
ja ich kann es auch bis zu einem
gewissen punkt nachvollziehen weil für
mich tatsächlich kunst mittlerweile
gleichbedeutend mit leben ist also
sozusagen die möglichkeit sich
auszudrücken kreativ zu sein ist das was
mich am leben hält und ich glaube in dem
moment wo mir das verwehrt sein würde
käme das tatsächlich sterben gleich
trotzdem aber sofort zum beispiel der
große schauspieler aus kurz wer weiß
dass hier wirklich etwas ist was viele
schauspieler derzeit im moment ist man
ja eine art des und 1 fast was zombies
käßmann ist als schauspieler noch da
aber das was ein lebendig macht das
fehlt ja und ich glaube deswegen
betreibe ich sehr viel aufwand trotzdem
kreativen output zu haben ich mache dann
halt andere sachen ich fotografiere im
moment sehr viel und die dann
stundenlang spazieren und und versuche
mich über über bilder auszudrücken ich
bin dann nicht sozusagen nur gebunden an
die schauspielerei ich versuche dann
mich auf anderen feldern zu betätigen
aber ohne dass tatsächlich einfach nur
zu hause zu sitzen und warten dass der
dass das sehr locker vorbei ist das ja
da würde ich mich tatsächlich fühlen wie
gestorben es gibt thomas mann so eine
schöne stelle daran muss ich gerade auf
denken tot sein ist der zustand in dem
man spricht und niemand hört ein
das ist die absolute resonanz losigkeit
es gibt kein publikum man ist ganz für
sich allein und das ist der zustand der
mensch eigentlich tot interessant ja
also ich weiß nicht wer jetzt von den
schweizer zuschauern die möglichkeit
hatte haben da zu sehen aber der tod ist
tatsächlich so inszeniert also in dem
moment
wo er den tödlichen hieb erfährt hamlet
redet er und die der rest der figuren
nimmt ihn nicht mehr wahr
das haben wieso alptraumhaft inszeniert
aber das finde ich auch ein sehr starkes
bild ist natürlich auch ein schauspieler
alptraum
man tut irgendetwas und niemand reagiert
ja ja ja deswegen deswegen finde ich
auch provokationen ein zu unrecht
negativ kommentiert begriff also weil
ich ich würde tatsächlich sagen dass ich
versuche mit meiner arbeit zu
provozieren aber nicht provokation um
der provokation willen oder um was
negatives zu produkt provozieren sondern
um eine reaktion zu genau fragen
gegenüber provokant was hervorrufen das
ist ja eine kunst die immer riskanter
seite und bringt uns auf ein thema das
die gesamte theater wert und auch die
filmbranche der zeit verändert
moralisiert vielleicht auch normiert
nämlich die frage wessen stücke mit
welchen schauspielern wie aufgeführt
werden sagt nico und seit der black life
center bewegung gibt es ja da sagen wir
mal einen neuen ein neues befragen was
derart dass auf sich selbst hinter das
auch sehr viel damit zu tun hat welche
provokation noch möglich oder gewünscht
werden wie erleben sie das derzeit von
ihnen ist dann wirklich eine dynamik von
ihnen herr spürbar wie man sie von außen
zu vernehmen meint ja absolut
also erstmal generell ich finde es total
wichtig dass die sprache überdacht wird
dass diese sachen überdacht werden auch
wenn ich da teilweise natürlich defizite
erlebe ja oder einschränkungen aber so
schmerzhaft dass jetzt ist für mich
persönlich ist es natürlich
gesellschaftlich enorm wichtig also auch
das verständnis darüber dass eine
gewisse gleichberechtigung nur dadurch
entstehen kann dass ich meine
privilegien aufgeben und das sind ja
privilegien privileg ist ich darf sicher
drei mit einem aufgestellten buckel
spielen
ich dachte es mal kurz zeigen weil
richard dritte ist ja so beispiel das
ist die rolle einer die sie auch an der
schaubühne gespielt haben und da gab es
tatsächlich menschen die gesagt haben
richard der dritte ist ein buckliger man
könnte sagen ein behinderter mensch und
da gab es menschen die sagen ja der
idinger spielt ja einen behinderten aber
ist gar nicht behindert das ist nicht in
ordnung
ja und es finde ich auch nachvollziehbar
die kritik auch wenn es mich natürlich
schmerzt ja und auch wenn ich natürlich
froh darum bin dass ich diese figur so
spielen darf aber es ist ein privileg
und ich muss mich dem stellen ich muss
mich fragen ist es richtig ist es
richtig mein fotoband autistisch disco
zu nennen wenn zu und so viele leute
gibt die sagen der begriff artistik in
dem zusammenhang den finde ich schwierig
ich habe da nicht so richtig eine lösung
ich finde gut dass es anfängt sich zu
bewegen so und ich stelle mich da auch
selber extremen frage aber trotzdem ist
natürlich auch die frage wo wohl sitzen
da die grenzen da geben wenn ich das
spiel wenn ich jetzt zb als hamlet im
fatsuit anziehe
also ihm etwas was ich sehr sehr dick
wirken lässt
es ist aber auch in gewisser weise eine
grenzüberschreitung ja weil man könnte
auch behaupten ich mache mich darüber
fettleibige menschen lustig oder das
hätte hätte was mit body shaping zu tun
oder ich hab ich habe in einem film von
jan bonny in einem polizeiruf in
deutschland ein transgender eine
transgender person gespielt und da fand
ich übrigens sehr interessant ich habe
mich sehr viel mit den mit tatsächlichen
transgender menschen unterhalten und die
haben gesagt sie möchten nicht sozusagen
das andere geschlecht werden oder sie
haben kein fable jetzt für das andere
geschlecht oder sie beispielsweise
weiblichkeit sondern sie möchten sie
selbst werden was ich eine interessante
erkenntnis für eine auch vor dem
hintergrund was will man als
schauspieler ich will mich ja nicht
verwandeln um jemand anders werden
sondern ich will mich verwandeln um mich
selbst zu werden so würden sie das
beschreiben ist ja weg zur selbst finden
ja absolut
und trotzdem ging es mir neulich so ich
hatte einen skype gespräch mit tim
robbins dem schauspieler weil es darum
ging schwesterlein der academy
vorzustellen
und da habe ich den begriff weil ich mir
auch in dem moment unsicher war habe ich
beide begriffe gesagt transsexuelle und
transgender und dann hat die produzentin
eingeschaltet und hat gesagt
könntest du den gedanken noch mal
formulieren ohne den begriff transaction
zu verwenden
dass so ein wort war das anders
kommentiert ist von dem sie vielleicht
wissen genau also ich war mir im
unklaren darüber aber es gibt
anscheinend ein problem mit dem wort und
und das meine ich finde da muss ich mich
stellen ich kann nicht einfach sagen ich
habe mein leben lang sexuell gesagt ich
sag das jetzt egal wer sich dadurch
verletzt fühlt oder ich sehe sozusagen
in dem begriff keine verletzung ist
scheint da eine zu geben und darauf muss
ich rücksicht
das ist glaube ich klar dass man für
sensibilitäten wasser wird dass man sie
überhaupt erst wahrnimmt als gegebene
sensibilitäten aber das was sie
beschreiben beispielsweise mit richard
dem dritten das geht ja in die innere
logik des schauspielern selbst wenn man
könnte sagen der ganze witz am
schauspielern besteht ja darin jemanden
darzustellen der mann nicht ist und wenn
man das nicht mehr darf dann kann man
kein schauspieler sein
das war auch meine erste reaktion dass
ich gedacht habe ja aber wenn ich jetzt
jemand ein spiegel der traurig ist und
bin gar nicht traurig erhebe ich mich
über alle die tatsächliche slide
erfahren ja ich mir steht es gar nicht
zu überhaupt mich in eine gewisse tragik
rhein zu denken weil ich dir in meinem
alltäglichen leben gar nicht so erfahren
aber ja ich glaube es ist ein
kompliziertes komplexes thema ich finde
es aber wichtig dass man sich die mühe
macht sich dem zu stellen und das nicht
von sich weg zu halten und sich auch
tatsächlich zu fragen inwieweit
profitiere ich denn von diesen
privilegien also ich finde schon
interessant dass ich glaube dass eine
80er jahre inszenierung von sadek wo
gehört vor sich noch schwarz angemalt
hat also und helau das würde auch
überhaupt nicht in frage diese black
facing wie man das heute ja ja und es
ist ja richtig dass man das in frage
stellt ja und ich glaube an einem
ähnlichen punkt sind wir in diesen
anderen fragen auch gerade und es ist
wichtig dass wir uns diese fragen
stellen
sie sind ja nun jemand der gerne vorne
raus geht der gerne provoziert er gerne
herausfordert wie sie angab ist dann
vielleicht den letzten zwei drei jahren
den gedanken war cool das projekt vor
zehn jahren hätte ich das gemacht aber
mittlerweile geht es nicht mit zu krass
ehrlich gesagt ja gut ich hab mal ein
angebot bekommen für eine rolle da
sollte ich jemanden spielen der auch so
hieß wie ich das ist aber das konzept
der serie dass alle so heißen wie sie
heißen und da ging es um die tu und da
war es so dass ich gedacht habe das
thema ist mir zu kompliziert und zu
komplex als dass ich es einfach nur
darstellen will ich möchte dann wissen
was die haltung sozusagen des
filmemachers zu dem thema ist und wollte
mich da nicht zur verfügung stellt das
war was da war ich plötzlich
sensibilisiert und habe gedacht die dem
die dem thema muss man auch den raum
einräumt den es verdient und kommt
glaube ich nicht weit in dem man sich
einfach so in statements flüchtet
statements ist ein gutes stichwort für
mich auch wenn es um angst geht ich habe
gelesen dass meryl streep ihn glaube ich
bei der berlinale zugeflüstert hat du
kannst mit einem einzigen satz seine
glaubwürdigkeit ruiniert
das ist ein satz der so wuchtig ist der
etwas über ruhm und star sein bedeutet
dann aber doch auch wirklich unter
extremen existenz druck setzt wenn
wirklich dieser eine satz die karriere
zerstören kann ja ich spür die angst
auch also könnten ganz konkret also
darin dass sich natürlich aber das sind
wir auch wieder bei privilegien
dadurch dass ich mich in meiner freiheit
eingeschränkt viele meiner ausdrucks in
meiner freiheit mich auszudrücken
aber ich weiß noch nicht ob das gut oder
schlecht ist aber ich bin natürlich in
gewisser weise als künstler darauf
angewiesen dass ich mich frei in den
raum äußern darf ohne dass wir zum
verhängnis wird
aber plötzlich spüre ich dann noch mehr
noch sie wie sie der trans kritik sie
müssen die grenzen die andere setzen
überschreiten und ja selber gesagt ja
genau
ja und da also man merkt schon also
sagen wir mal so ich glaube der der
punkt ist dass sprache verräterisch ist
und dass ich mich natürlich in meinem
denken oft verraten
und dass das richtig ist dass
anzukreiden
weil einfach nur zu sagen da hat den
einen satz gesagt und das kann jetzt
nicht der grund sein warum er
ein shitstorm erfährt oder degradiert
wird ich muss mich schon fragen woher
kommt dieser satz warum warum formuliere
ich den so welches denken steckt
dahinter
und ich glaube dass man das schon oft
auch über sich selber erstaunt ist oder
überrascht ist was da für personen in
einem hausen yamaha sei mit der
sozialisierung zu tun ja so wie meine
eltern noch geredet haben der
sprachgebrauch meiner eltern auch auf
mich auf meiner schulzeit und davon muss
ich mich natürlich erstmal entfernen da
muss ich gewisse sachen erstmal in frage
stellen
bei mir zuhause wo du noch gesagt als
alice schwarzer auf dem bildschirm
erschienen die dumme sei und dass das
ist ja extremer schritt den ich gehen
muss als persönlichkeit zu sagen ist es
wirklich eine dumme sau oder ist es
nicht eine frau der wir wahnsinnig viel
zu verdanken haben weil sie sich für
frauenrechte eingesetzt hat aber aber
diesen diese die diese transferleistung
die muss man erst mal bringen
man muss sich ja erst mal in innere
distanz begeben um darauf zu schauen und
zu sagen jetzt steig mal vielleicht
diese werte die mir da noch zuhause
vermittelt wurden vielleicht stimmt die
gandhi man mit der muttermilch sozusagen
eingesaugt ja und die einem ganz
selbstverständlich erscheinen und ich
glaube bis heute ist es so dass sprache
ein dahingehend verrät und dass man oft
ich habe zum beispiel um zusammen mit
einem anderen film habe ich gesagt
einmal pussy ja als ich das gemacht habe
was ängstlich war oder so
ja genau ich bin ich bin in der nazi
uniform einem schäferhund vorbeigelaufen
der mich angemeldet hat und
zurückgewichen und ich sollte aber
jemand martialisches spielen und dann
bin ich zurück auf anfang
der szene und habe zu dem kollegen
gesagt ich bin ne pause und dann hat der
kollege gesagt pussy wie rhede sind ja
er hat ja völlig recht also
würde ich nie wieder sagen aber es kam
so raus und ich muss mich dann sozusagen
trotzdem fragen welches weltbild stellte
steckt dahinter welche die wiwi schaue
ich auf die frauen was welt welchen an
oder wie stehe ich zur feministin und so
dass das sind ja alles fragen die muss
ich die muss ich mir doch stellen
sozusagen nur dadurch kann man doch eine
veränderung hervorrufen in dem man sich
in frage stellt und nicht daran dass man
sagt ich brauche ich bin aber überhaupt
nicht frauenfeindlich und ich bin auch
nicht rassistisch vielleicht müssen wir
erstmal an den punkt kommen wo wir uns
den den eigenen den eigenen fremdenhass
oder die fremdenfeindlichkeit und den
eigenen sexismus eingestehen um
überhaupt eine veränderung zu
provozieren von all den dingen die man
mitnimmt
ohne dass man sie reflektiert hat in der
erziehung im zeitgeist in dem werden wie
es hinter jetzt eine generation sagen in
den 70er jahren als als männer
sozialisiert worden wir haben sport
gemacht wir haben da vieles an
heldischen und an idealen von
männlichkeit in uns aufgenommen die wir
über die wir nie nachgedacht hatten und
die letzten 20 jahren mussten wir sehen
dass diese selbstverständlichkeiten
keine waren
ich finde dass in ihrem fall auch so
besonders interessant weil sie nicht nur
ein rollenmodell sind aufgrund des
staates dass sie haben sondern weil man
ihn auch immer zu schreibt dass sie für
eine neue männlichkeit stehen und zwar
in einer paradoxen weise einerseits sind
sie physisch sehr imposant wirkt sehr
männlich und dann sagt man immer es gibt
diese zerbrechlichkeit es gibt dieses
ganz und gar fragile in ihn und da
werden sie zu einem typus aufgebaut der
fast für ein neues geschlechter idee hat
steht nämlich so eine art neue
männlichkeit wie sie sein sollte ja aber
ich sehe mich da überhaupt nicht als
botschafter also ich freue mich darüber
ich bin mir aber hundertprozentig sicher
dass jetzt schon zu viele aufschreien
und sagen was der typ und so also das
ist für mich das gegenteil von einem
modernen mann
wenn ich mir jetzt beispielsweise die
fingernägel an male dann ist es eine
befreiung vor mir selbst
also ich
macht das was ich schön finde weil es
attraktiv finde und weil ich die grenze
überschreite dass ich eigentlich denke
max lieber nicht ich würde gerne aber
ich habe zu viel angst davor wie mein
gegenüber darauf reagiert und darunter
habe ich als teenager sehr gelitten dass
ich eine vorstellung davon hatte wie ich
gerne wäre wie ich gern aussehen würde
und habe mich immer zurückgehalten und
irgendwann kam der punkt ist gesagt ich
muss mich da befreien da kam sehr spät
bei mir aber es habe ich auch als
solches empfunden und das finde ich
tatsächlich auch aufregend also mit
einem kleid auf die straße zu gehen ist
aufregend und dann kann man fragen kann
man sich fragen stellt man sich dieser
aufregung und und läuft man auch gefahr
darüber dafür ausgelacht zu werden oder
angegriffen zu werden und unter und da
habe ich einfach für mich gemerkt es
bringt mich weiter mich dahingehend auch
zu fordern und mich dem auszusetzen
aber ich weiß ich hab ich habe im jahr
2007 film gemacht wird maren ades alle
anderen
das war eine art durchbruch für den für
sie als frau diana damals und ich finde
dass maren ades in dem film auftrat
nahezu prophetisch art diese ganze
problematik vorweggenommen da taucht er
mich dieser satz auf findest du mich
eigentlich männlich und dann wird
durchexerziert was heißt es eigentlich
dann malt sie mich an wie ein mädchen
dann dann gesteht der mann seine
schwäche einer sagt er weiß nicht so
richtig was er machen soll beruflich und
sorgen dass interessante phänomen ist
dass er darüber unattraktiv wird
und das stellt sozusagen auch unser
wertesystem komplett in frage also ist
ein mann der schwach es ist ein mann der
weich ist er weint und weich ist denn
überhaupt noch attraktiv für eine frau
ich finde es sagt sich so leicht aber
ich kenne wirklich sehr viele frauen wie
wenn man fragt was findest du eine man
attraktiv sagen ich finde man attraktiv
der mich dominiert und ich schäme sich
auch dafür dass sie das sagen aber sie
sagen ohne dass die präparate sowie
klaus und dieser problematik muss man
sich stellen
ist sozusagen dieser mann dem wir
einfordern überhaupt der den wir
begehren können oder müssen wir auch
unsere eigene sicht auch die frau
sozusagen noch mal hinterfragen so also
wie gesagt ich freue mich über so eine
beschreibung aber ich habe irgendwann
mal durchkam diesen podest zu stehen
oder das ist ja nur enormer druck wenn
ihr also neue männliche da fühlt sich
frau gesagt man soll das fühlt sich für
mich nicht so an ich habe mal ich hab
mal ich habe mal einen preis gewonnen
und krawattenträger des jahres und erst
konnte ich damit gar nichts einfach ich
habe einfach eine mail bekommen sie sind
zum krawattenträger des jahres gekürt
worden und dann habe ich mir aber die
begründung der jury durchgelesen und da
stand dass er wie selbstverständlich
sender grenzen sprengt und das fand ich
ein satz der mir gefallen hat weil diese
selbstverständlichkeit
er hat mir gefallen das ist man wünscht
sich ja sozusagen eine zeit in der
keiner mehr über lackierte fingernägel
bei männern spricht weil es einfach
selbstverständlich ist und ich glaube da
muss man hinkommen
man könnte ja sagen wir fangen mal an
mit dieser bina binären unterscheidung
mann und frau wenn man heute die
wissenschaftler seht ihr sagen es gibt
so ein kontinuum da gibt es kein
entweder oder sondern wir sind alle auf
einem spektrum und dieses spektrum
variiert durch die ganze zeit dann wäre
ja dann ein ziel auch vielleicht das
schauspielern zu sagen ich zeig euch
wieso ein kontinuum aussehen kann ich
gehe das kontinuum für euch durch weil
ihr alle eigentlich dieses continum in
euch habt in mehr oder weniger starker
form ja ich glaube so ein bisschen
verstehe ich meinen beruf aus
tatsächlich was an ihrem beruf und wie
sie ihn verstehen für mich auch
faszinierend ist dass sie nicht nur
mutig sind sondern dass sie das unter
extremen körperlichen einsatz vorbringen
zb gibt es da dieses video das sie mit
der gruppe deichkind gedreht haben in
der sie zu einem männlichen pinsel
werden und sich auf einer leinwand
minuten lang durch schleifen lassen
geradezu als ob sie sagen wollten ich
bin gar kein leib und seele ich bin nur
leicht drei bist alles was ich bin
ja das war interessantes das video ist
ein jahr alt
es war die idee von henning besser das
ist sozusagen der kreative kopf hinter
deichkind und er rief mich an und meinte
sie haben die idee eine 20 quadratmeter
große leinwand auf den boden zu legen
mit einem kran hochzuziehen in einen
bottich farbe zu tunken und mit mir ein
bild zu malen
das klingt ja erst mal interessant als
idee aber das muss man erstmal umsetzen
dafür bewundere ich die wirklich
zutiefst dass sie das schaffen dass sie
in der lage sind so eine idee in die
realität umzusetzen da muss man erst mal
machen sich darauf hängen lassen und
durch schleifen lassen ich stell mir das
geradezu schmerzhaft da gab es dann auch
natürlich die erste diskussion ich
wollte dann ich dachte es sieht
unvorteilhaft aus wenn ich da hänge und
nackt bin ich wollte eine unterhose an
haben dann habe das ausprobiert aber
irgendwie komisch als man hat so viel
über die unterhose nachgedacht dann will
der muss es nackt machen das erinnert
auch viel mehr so an diesen aktionstag
malerei aus den 70ern und dann gab es
jemand der das betreut hat er gesagt hat
wie lange kann ich da oben hängen und
sich ohnmächtig werde dann war die
schwierigkeit mich in diesem bottich ein
zu tunken weil ich da aus eigener kraft
nicht raus konnte und natürlich sehr
viel vertrauen haben musste dass die
mich auch irgendwann wieder raus ziehen
und dann war die schwierigkeit dass ich
mit 90 kilo auf einer leinwand steht das
stellt sich tatsächlich da wie
schmirgelpapier also man hätte
wahrscheinlich seiten nehmen müssen aber
durch das gewicht weil es so rau diese
oberfläche ich hab' ich war unter dieser
blauen farbe weil ich wirklich
blutüberströmt und und das war extrem
schmerzhaft aber alles für mich vorher
jemand fragen würde diese diese schmerz
komme auf dich zu machst du das würde
ich wahrscheinlich sagen nein aber ich
wusste ja auch vorher nicht was da auf
mich zukommen
wie weit würden sie denn gegen ich habe
von ihnen satz gelesen wenn ein
regisseur zu mir sagen würde du musst
dir für die rolle den arm abschneiden
vor der kamera würde ich zumindest
apriori nicht sagen mach ich nicht
ja das habe ich aber nur in bezug auf
lars von trier knallrot aber einmal bin
ich mir nicht den arm abhacken
aber ja ich glaube es ist da kommt man
komme ich komme so zusagen zurück zu dem
begriff stage animal
mich interessiert sehr diese grauzone
zwischen dem was gespielt ist und was
real ist weil ich glaube dass es diese
unterscheidung gar nicht wirklich gibt
da gibt es diese sind dieses tolle zitat
von bernd meinunger aus dem text von
katja ebstein theater theater alles ist
nur theater und das doch auch
wirklichkeit also dieser punkt zu sagen
in der fiktion bin ich ja trotzdem
leibhaftig anwesend
das heißt wenn ich da als pinsel über
die leinwand gezogen habe ich ja
trotzdem real als mensch schmerzen und
wenn ich emotional werde in der figur
wenn ich ja trotzdem emotional also es
sei denn man hat man man hilft sich mit
mit einem trend stift oder irgendwelchen
tricks aber wenn man wie ich den
anspruch hat es auch wirklich zu
durchleben
dann wird es teil meines erlebten lebens
und und und und und deswegen gefällt mir
dieses animalische weil zum beispiel
gibt es sachen wie eine erektion die
sind nicht künstlich er schleift die
unmittelbarkeit einfach umgehauen hat
sie ist das was sie ist und dort und das
übt auf mich eine extreme faszination
aus und auch ein schmerz natürlich
also wenn ich wenn ich sage jemand
schlägt mich wirklich ins gesicht und
ich filme ist und ich profitiere davon
was es mit mir macht und das ist
sichtbar und ich stellte sozusagen zur
verfügung das wird auch gebannt und es
wird sozusagen der der danach weil zur
verfügung gestellt finde ich das bereits
für den ich bereit bin sehr viel opfer
zu bringen also in der probe würde ich
das jetzt nicht machen oder wenn sie
keine aufnimmt sondern es geht natürlich
auch darum zu sagen man man stellt es
der öffentlichkeit zur verfügung
aber das ist ja auch ein punkt nehmen
wir mal an man hat einer eine 610
erotische szene und man steigert sich da
so rein dass man auf der bühne jetzt
eine erektion bekäme das zum beispiel
dass sie genannt haben
das ist ja auch der moment maximaler und
verfügbarkeit kann man sagen maximale
intensität aber so verletzlich wird man
ja nie wieder
also man setzt sich wirklich vollkommen
aus ja und ich empfinde es als eine
wahnsinnige qualität also auch weil er
genau die die die unterschiedlichsten
gefühle die sich auch vordergründig
widersprechen zusammenkommen das heißt
es ist ein moment absoluter verletzt
verletzlichkeit und charme heftigkeit
und gleichzeitig eine absolut ein gefühl
von erhabenheit und potenzial und potenz
also ich hatte mal einen film von peter
greenaway gold gold gold center pelican
company 2 film und peter greenaway
beschreibt er wirklich über seiten auch
den sexuellen akt und da war eigentlich
klar
da bin ich als schauspieler gefordert
eine erektion zu haben und dann haben
wir die szene geprobt und dann habe ich
peter greenaway gefragt wie man es denn
mit der edition und er hat mir einfach
das gefühl gegeben er vertraut mir da ja
ich habe mir selber gar nicht vertraut
ich habe selber das wird gar nicht
funktionieren und es ging dann aber in
der szene und das hatte ganz viel damit
zu tun dass ich das gefühl hatte dass
gegenüber die schauspielerin gegenüber
bringt mir vertrauen entgegen gegen das
vertrauen das ich mich in dem moment
schutzlos zeigen kann und da konnte ich
mich dann so öffnen dass sich sexuell
erregt waren das hat eine große roddick
man sagt ja auch so man erkennt sich
anderen angesagter typische interviews
iron man erkennt einander wenn man sich
vollkommen schutzlos hingibt genau und
trotzdem würde ich das gefühl was ich in
dem moment hatte als wahnsinnig
ambivalent und komplex beschreiben und
zwar war es eine schamhaft ich kite und
es war ein großes gefühl von macht und
potenz und das ist natürlich irre wenn
diese wenn diese emotionen die sich
scheinbar so widersprechen gleichzeitig
stattfinden
gibt es da noch das interessiert mich
weil es faszinierend ist so was zu hören
gibt's ja noch sozusagen eine dritte
instanz die sagte guck mal
du hast jetzt eine erektion gibt es dann
noch eine reflektion instanz wo sie
sagen ich schau mir dabei zu und denke
bin da ganz schön seltsam erklärt ja ja
die gibt es immer die gibt's auch in
hoch emotionalen ziehen also ich merke
auch beim spielen wenn die wenn ich mich
öffne und wenn die emotion einsetzt oder
wenn wenn der körper reagiert und mir
die tränen runter fließen bin ich auf
der einen seite also es ist wirklich ein
hochkomplexer vorgang wie ich auf der
einen seite natürlich traurig oder
verzweifelt was zu dieser körperlichen
reaktionen führt aber es gibt auch ein
absolutes glücksgefühl von wow die
kamera läuft und mir gelingt es gerade
ohne dass es dazu führt dass es eine dem
anderen widerspricht und das ist
vielleicht aufhört sondern es findet
alles gleichzeitig statt
und ich glaube das ist auch das weswegen
man schauspielerei als was rauschhaftes
beschreiben kann weil es eine absolute
form von bewusstseinserweiterung ist
also ich kann in so einem moment
wirklich alles gleichzeitig wahrnehmen
und ich habe mal ein interview geführt
in barcelona mit einer simultanen
übersetzerin die gesagt hat sie ist
immer dann gut wenn sie während sie
übersetzt noch darüber nachdenken kann
dass sie ihre tochter im anschluss von
der schule abholt dann ist sie gut und
ich hätte früher als schauspieler immer
gesagt seine gegner zu haben ich dachte
immer ich bin schlecht weil ich mich
fokussiert bin mittlerweile weiß ich
dass ich dann gut bin wenn alles
gleichzeitig stattfindet also wenn wir
uns unterhalten ich dem gedanken folgen
kann ich aber auch in einem vollen
bewusstsein darüber bin dass da ein
kamerateam ist es da dass die jeder
spiegel es ist glas wasser mein anzug
alles gleichzeitig und das ist dass das
etwas rauschhaftes da könnte man sagen
das ist das volle glitzern der wirklich
nehme alles gleichzeitig war und ich
nehme die ganzen reichtum des möglichen
resonanz ist ja das ist präsent war dann
aber das ist auch was woran ich mich
eigentlich mein leben lang abgearbeitet
habe an der tragik dass den moment
festzuhalten oder den moment zu erleben
utopisch ist das ist eigentlich nicht
funktioniert weil das leben beschreibt
bewegung deswegen ist der satz auch so
treffend der rest ist schweigen er der
erste stelle entschuldigung deswegen ist
der gedanke so treffen zu sagen stille
im sinne von
stillstand weil in dem moment wo ich
lebe bewegte sich und das schließt aus
dass ich dem moment überhaupt erfahren
weil der moment existiert nicht er ist
nie fest sondern ist alles im fluss und
und damit muss ich mich im besten sinne
abfinden oder arrangieren nur dann kann
ich mein leben genießen aber in der
verzweiflung oder selbiges lange
empfunden oder in der tragik dass man
dem moment festhalten will
das macht dann unglücklich und das ist
auch so eine sehnsucht nach einer form
von perfektion die tatsächlich sich erst
im tod ein lösen würde da würde man
sagen die unmittelbarste intensität die
gibt es nur um tod weil in der
philosophie ist 20 interessant was ich
sagen gibt es zusagen zwei intensität
ideale nehmen wir mal beim sex man
könnte sagen man hat dann guten sex wenn
man nicht mehr darüber nachdenkt sex zu
haben sondern reines handeln ist und sie
haben es beschrieben nein es gibt ein
anderes intensität ideal
es ist das komplette handeln und das
wissen um die komplexität und die
komplette us handel ja das ist die volle
präsenz genau ja interessant
also ich würde auch sagen der
selbstvergessene moment ist für mich im
grunde wertlos
ich möchte ihr sozusagen der
selbstbewusste moment den finde ich
erstrebenswert und das hat mich immer
gestört dass ich gesagt habe rückwirkend
war ich in dem moment glücklich aber in
dem moment wo ich den moment erlebt habe
war ich mir dessen gar nicht bewusst wie
gut ist könnte man sagen es ist
vielleicht das ideal dass es nichts
rationales hat das ganz animalischer ja
aber also ich ich ich habe oder
vielleicht ist es auch einfach so ich
habe große schwierigkeiten damit mich
selbst zu vergessen das ist vielleicht
auch was an dem ich mich abarbeite
vielleicht wünschte ich mir manchmal
selbst vergessen dazu seien aber ich
habe dann doch immer drauf blick und es
ist zum beispiel auch interessant dass
ich mich wenn mich jemand heimlich
gefilmt und mir das zeigt ertrage ich
mich nicht
ich ertrage mich nur in der gestaltung
also in dem wo ich ein bewusstsein dafür
habe wie ich rede was ich sage indem und
durch eine kontrolle habe aber in dem
unkontrollierten moment finde ich mich
unausstehlich und das ist aber nichts wo
ich sage das ist
das ist ein zustand über die nicht
glücklich bin sondern ich das ist etwas
woran ich arbeite also von selbst
annahme so bin ja ja genau
also ich meine man merkt ist ja schon da
dabei wenn man jetzt nicht in den
spiegel guckt jeder von uns nimmt vom
spiegel selbst alleine position ein
in der einigermaßen vorteilhaften wird
keiner von uns wird sich so im spiegel
zeigen wie wir wirklich aus das kennt
jeder wenn es handy versehentlich angeht
und und und und man sieht und fordert
erschrickt man ja förmlich vor seinem
eigenen gesicht dabei ist es das gesicht
so sieht man aus ja und wie viele
menschen also maskieren sich sogar vor
dem spiel am sonntag face oder also man
geht er in seine form von schutz
ja und das ist leute grinsen wenn die
kamera an ist und macht mal foto und so
genau und ich glaube in diesem zwiespalt
befinde ich mich im grunde dass ich eine
sehnsucht danach aber diesen schutz
fallen zu lassen aber darum weiß wie
viel mut erfordert und wie viel
schmerzen ist eigentlich auch mit sich
bringt sich selbst anzunehmen
sie sind ja nun nicht nur schauspieler
sondern auch künstler sie streben danach
diese dynamik in anderen künsten
aufzusuchen zum beispiel als fotograf
oder als dj würden sie dann sagen das
geht in der musik als dj
diese resonanz suche der selbstaufgabe
ist das ähnlich wie mit dem schauspiel
war natürlich sind ja djs menschen die
stimmungen erspüren und dann verstärken
oder mit diesen stimmungen spielen man
könnte sagen ist eigentlich wie
schauspiel nur dass der text die musik
ist oder ist es ganz anders dort oh nee
das ist genauso als es auch tatsächlich
ein erhabenes gefühl diese stimmung zu
bestimmen also ich tanze auch gerne oder
ich gehe auch gern in clubs und gebe
mich sozusagen dem dj hin aber ich bin
auch gerne der der für diese stimmung
verantwortlich ist ein hohepriester her
ich mache mir naja diesen diesem
gottesdienst der selbsterfahrung
ja es wird ja sehr viel über über
applaus philosophiert oder es für
schauspieler wird oft unterstellt dass
sie auf applaus aus und das ist
gibt es aber nicht ganz den applaus
finde ich tatsächlich nicht wirklich
interessant sondern den interessanten
moment für mich wenn ich wenn ich spiele
und eine gewisse aufmerksamkeit genieße
und die leute auch geistig bei mir sind
also wenn ich das gefühl habe
uns verbindet in dem moment war es also
und das erlebe ich auch beim musikmachen
dass ich das gefühl habe es entsteht
etwas was größer ist als die summe der
anwesenden und ich meine es wird jetzt
wahrscheinlich zu weit aber das ist
tatsächlich dann dann gibt es um
transzendenz und das ist dann das ideal
dass ich in dem moment merke da passiert
was was was größer ist was was was was
überirdisch ist und was eine energie
meint oder beschreibt nachdem man eine
sehnsucht hat ja und das kann man
provozieren und das dass das gibt dann
natürlich ein wahnsinnig erhabenes
gefühl wir sind jetzt in der stunde für
sophia street nicht zu weit und konzerte
der wahre begriff wo wir würden wie es
dann fassen ist die transzendenz so zu
beschreiben dass was nur ein bewusstsein
in sich eingekapselt ist sich aus
kapselt und aufnahme sucht mit den
energien der anderen bewusstsein und
dass sie dann eins werden ja ja ja
absolut
also dass da hängt dann auch nicht der
vergleich zur sexualität sehr genau dass
das bestreben und trotzdem stört mich
ein bisschen an dem beschreibung 1
werden dass es dann nur um die
verschmelzung geht sondern es geht
tatsächlich noch darum mehr zu werden
also dass das dass man das gefühl hat er
entsteht was jeder erreicht qualitativ
eine neue ebene aber nur gemeinsam genau
und das ist ja schon verblüffend das ist
überhaupt geht ich war ich habe mich mal
in einem film mit georg trakl
beschäftigt der das ideal der eigenen
geschlechtlichkeit hatte
und sozusagen die annahme dass das übel
die ursache allen übels die trennung von
mann und frau ist und deswegen finde ich
den begriff im englischen auch so
treffend sex weil er sozusagen sowohl
die geschlechter unterscheidet als auch
den sexuellen akt beschreibt und darum
geht es eigentlich in um die begegnung
und um das verschmelzen und tatsächlich
auch um das auflösen von von gender
unterschieden und das ist ja auch
interessant zu sagen vor dem hintergrund
der problematik was beschreibt
feminismus sexismus
das ist eigentlich das ziel wäre diese
diese unterteilung dass das dass die
sich auflösung das dass der ständige
kampf des menschen ist eigentlich auch
und deswegen gibt es ja den sexuellen
akt weil er sozusagen nichts anderes
meint als dass man sich vereinigt die
differenz die bleibt ich war es ist ja
kein student differenzierende erfahrung
ja ja das ist auch übrigens ein sehr
interessanter gedanke vor dem
hintergrund des films schwesterlein weil
die beiden regisseurinnen die kennen
sich seit sie glaube ich im kindergarten
war sind selbst schwesterlein sie
absolut ja und im grunde ist es auch
meine erkenntnis dass filmemacher
letztendlich in egal welchem thema sie
sich stellen von ihrer eigenen
persönlichkeit erzählen und in dem fall
kriegt man tatsächlich die
persönlichkeit dieser beiden menschen
beschrieben und das faszinierende ist
dass wir auf der einen seite nahezu
symbiotisch sind aber trotzdem ihre
individuellen die individualität nicht
aufgeben
und ja so ist es wahrscheinlich im
idealfall in der sexualität auch eben
dass die differenz sich eher gegenseitig
bestärkt dass das er sich vollkommen auf
hegt wir haben jetzt wie ich finde eine
extrem beeindruckender weise eine art
erkenntnis programm des schauspielens
ausgelegt und sie machen auch andere
künstler haben sie denn derzeit pläne
ideen in welchen anderen medien sich
dieser drang noch form geben kann für
sie
ja also im moment bin ich sehr glücklich
mit der fotografie ich hatte ja das
große glück jetzt im jahr 2020 ein
bildband genau auszugeben autistisch
disko no
bei hatje cantz und ich habe gemerkt wie
viel freude es mir macht über die bilder
zu kommunizieren und wie ungern ich
eigentlich darüber rede
also es gab dann diverse versuche auch
in berichterstattung mich zu befragen
was ich mit diesen bildern sagen will
und es ist dann fast die diebische
freude das nicht preiszugeben weil auf
der einen seite könnte ich's tatsächlich
also es ist auch das was mich am meisten
reizt beim fotografieren mir ein bild
anzugucken zu und zu erleben was macht
es mit mir das motiv aber was mich viel
mehr interessiert ist das ist nicht
erkläre und dass ich darauf spekulieren
dass es beim gegenüber für etwas ganz
anderes auslöst weil das verrückte und
da entsteht da versteht man glaube ich
ein grundlegendes prinzip von kunst dass
die interpretation eine
selbstbeschreibung ist also wenn jemand
meinen bildern ironie unterstellt hat
etwas mit ihm zu tun nicht mit mir das
urteil urteilt über den der urteile ja
und das ist doch das ist doch verrückt
auch als selbsterkenntnis moment das man
sagen man kann meine bilder benutzen um
zu verstehen wie es in einem selbst aus
nicht in nicht in mir das ist völlig
egal wer die bilder gemacht hat und was
der damit aussagen das ist völlig
zweitrangig wichtig ist was das bild mit
mir macht deswegen ist für mich auch
dass das dass das monochrome blau von
yves klein das wichtigste bild gewesen
schon immer weil weil ich wirklich
erstaunt bin darüber was ist mit mir
gemacht hat ich habe das damals gesehen
es gab damals dependance vom guggenheim
in berlin in der unter den linden gibt
es inzwischen nicht mehr
und da habe ich dieses bild gesehen und
ich konnte wirklich nicht fassen ich
konnte es nicht glauben dass da jemand
sich trauten bild aufzuhängen
was blau ist und was und mit einem blau
bemalt dass er sich auch noch
patentieren lässt und das ist dann auch
eine art spiegel der selbst erkennt ja
absolut und wenn wir jetzt am ende sind
wir bei gespräche immer landen müssen
dass es auch ein erkenntnis des lebens
ist das natürlich ein motiv der kunst
dieses erkenne dich selbst durch das
bild das die anderen einem geben
sie haben uns wundervoll breite mal das
heute gezeigt heidinger vielen dank dass
sie dabei ja danke für die einladung
[Musik]